- Today we're gonna do
a what's on my iPad.
I've been using my iPad so much more
since we've been in quarantine.
Since I've been spending
so much time at home,
I've been editing on my Mac Pro,
so I don't necessarily
use my MacBook as much.
So now I've been using my
iPad for everything else,
but editing.
I've been using it to edit
photos, to play games,
I've also been using it
to watch Twitch streams,
watching YouTube videos,
I've been using it to track my food,
like I wanna go through and show you guys
all the apps that I've been using.
Someone asked me the other day,
if I was on a deserted island,
what piece of tech would I take,
and normally I would have said my iPhone.
But I think I might
change that to the iPad,
iPad Pro with magic
keyboard and Apple Pencil.
So I guess that's three things.
No, that's just one.
This is one package (laughs).
Before we get into what
else is on my iPad,
I need to talk about Raid Shadow Legends.
A huge thank you to them
for sponsoring this video.
A few weeks ago they reached out,
and asked if I had ever played
the game and at that point,
no, I had not played it.
I'd seen so many of my
friends playing it before,
so I thought that I would give it a shot,
since I have a lot of free time,
and basically all I've been doing is,
playing video games anyway.
What I love about this game,
is obviously the graphics are
awesome, I love RPG games.
But this is a game that
I can keep playing,
while I'm also doing something else.
I'll get into that in a second.
It's free to play and the graphics,
are actually really good.
It's not really a mobile game,
because you could also play it on PC.
I love when games give you
daily rewards for logging in.
They've also upped the daily
login rewards from 90 to 180,
So I kind of have my daily ritual now,
while I'm having my
coffee, I open up the game,
collect my rewards, play a few battles,
upgrade my champions,
and then I can continue on with my day.
If you guys want to join my clan,
my username is iju5tine.
You guys want to check the game out,
click the link in the description.
For all new players for the next 30 days,
you'll get 100,000 silver, 50
gems, one free energy refill,
plus the executioner
who's a rare champion,
from the Knight Revenant.
And all of all those
rewards will be available,
right up here.
I mentioned the autoplay.
I like to use this mode
in the easier battles,
when I know I'm gonna win,
and I don't have to put forth much effort.
So while I'm writing email, or editing,
I can be over here working
on upgrading champions,
raiding dungeons, and also going
through the campaign modes.
I feel like I'm just
scratching the surface,
being a few weeks in.
Oh, in the new 1.15 patch,
you'll be able to compete
in the new arena tournament.
So you will be able to
compete locally and globally,
to be able to get really cool rewards.
So now let's continue on with
the what's on my iPad video.
Now my iPad's dead because I
didn't charge it last night,
and I've been playing games.
Hold on, I need to charge.
Oh, did somebody say
pass through charging?
They did.
So here's everything
that I have on my iPad.
The first page is just
really not that interesting,
because I don't ever actually
swipe to find my apps,
I swipe down.
I type okay, I want Twitter,
Twitter shows up.
I want Twitch, Twitch shows up.
I want email, email shows up.
So this first page is kind
of all the basic Apple apps.
You've got FaceTime, Calendar, Clock,
all the way through to the
measuring app, to settings,
and then it starts getting
into my actual apps.
I have Gmail, Control Center,
which I use to control my Elgato lights
at my streaming setup.
Streaming slash zoom
slash conference call,
slash video game setup.
This is the Microsoft Teams app.
So I use that a lot of times
when I'm doing different conference calls.
People use so many different
conferencing systems now.
Twitch, I think we all
know what Twitch is.
MyFitnessPal, I've been trying really hard
to track the foods that I eat,
especially during quarantine.
MyFitnessPal is a really not
fun reality of food tracking.
I don't think I've tracked
anything yet today.
Next we have Photo Booths.
I don't think I've ever
actually ever opened this,
on my iPad.
Oh, cool.
Yeah, that's a good shot, that's great.
I'm gonna make that my profile picture.
Shortcuts for creating Siri shortcuts.
These are still Apple's
things, iTunes or Tabs.
I need to put these all in a folder.
GarageBand, that's what
I've been using to record
my podcasts with my sister.
Keynote, Numbers, Pages,
iMovie, iTunes U, Houzz.
LumaFusion for editing.
I love LumaFusion so much.
This is one of my favorite apps.
This is how I feel like I could survive,
by just using an iPad.
And now especially with the track pad,
like, oh, so good.
Lightroom for editing photos,
Hot Lava is another Apple arcade game,
Angry Birds,
that's a VR game that I
covered in my iPad video.
Minecraft Earth, Shapr3D, Statue
of Liberty also an AR app,
Jedi Challenges,
Forensics Detective that was
also the game that I covered.
- [Announcer] Access forensic tools,
that will help you tie the
evidence to one or more suspects.
- Nettie, I'm trying to
solve a crime right now.
Leo AR.
That's an AR camera that
has been around for a while.
IKEA store.
An IKEA place those
kind of go hand in hand,
with the IKEA place app,
is the one that allows you to
place items into your space.
Oh, let me try to put this chair.
This looks great.
So right here, I'm gonna put
the chair outside of my studio.
It's crazy 'cause you can
like move it around too.
So obviously that doorframe wasn't there.
You wouldn't even be able to tell,
if that chair wasn't there.
Monster Park.
This is also really funny.
Okay, I'm placing my scene.
Look at my little guy.
Oh my gosh this is so cool.
Look at this dinosaur, hi friend.
Tap any place on the ground
to get the dino, over here.
Who needs friends when you
have this game in quarantine.
Froggipedia, you can dissect a frog,
TikTok, I think we all know what that is.
I also have Excel and Word on here,
because my sister and I have
been using spreadsheets,
to track items that we
want in Animal Crossing.
I know it's absurd.
Apogee MetaRecorder.
That's what I use the height mic for,
I can record it directly on my iPad.
HBO Go, I've been watching Westworld.
This season is really good.
Like I love Aaron Paul so much.
But I feel like there's
a weird disconnect,
between what's actually happening.
There's so many storylines
happening at the same time.
I'm not sure if it's just me,
but I've been getting very
confused trying to follow along.
I am a few episodes behind,
so I feel like there's
probably a lot more questions,
that have been answered
in the latest episodes.
Instagram.
I love Instagram so much,
but the fact that they
don't have an iPad app,
infuriates me.
Instagram is Facebook,
and if they're gonna say
that they don't have
enough developers to work
on making a native app for the iPad,
I'll freaking do it myself.
Let me open up Xcode.
I'm not sure what the reason is,
but whatever the reason
is, it's not valid.
Let's see what's happening
on Instagram today.
Oh, what a really crappy
experience this is.
Lemme just turn my iPad
so that I can enjoy.
Nope, still not enjoying the experience.
I love Instagram.
This is stupid.
I don't get upset very
often, but this upsets me.
I've said my piece.
Brava, that connects to my oven,
so that's what I use to cook.
Peloton.
I'm such a huge fan of the peloton app.
I don't really use it on my iPad as much,
'cause I do have the treadmill.
They've got a bunch of different classes.
You don't have to have a bike,
you don't have to have the treadmill,
they have all of these
classes that are digital.
And also if you are a runner,
that you'd like to run outdoors,
they have just some audio classes,
that you can follow along
and do outdoor runs.
I've never considered myself a runner,
until I started doing
these running classes.
Like I've been able to over
the past, I guess year,
work up to being able to run over an hour,
which I never thought that I would ever,
ever be able to do that.
So that is one of the things
that I did accomplish during quarantine.
I've done several hour runs,
and I honestly owe it all to Peloton.
'cause I've just been
following through their class,
and I started doing just
like 10 minute walks on this,
worked my way up to 20,
and then 30, and then 45,
and I was like okay, if I can do 45,
that must mean I could
probably push myself
an extra 15 minutes and do the hour.
MediaSilo, that's for
transferring footage.
Ring O2, that's an app that
I was using for a ring,
that you could detect
your blood oxygen levels.
I don't know, once the
whole Corona thing happened,
I was paranoid and
wanted to be able to test
all of my vitals.
Director and Capture.
This is really cool,
this is called Cenna maker.
So this allows you to use your iPad,
basically like a live studio.
So I can pull in four different streams,
from various iOS devices,
and create a live show,
or a pre-recorded show using my iPad.
Canva is a really cool
Photoshop for iPad app.
We also have YouTube studio.
That's what I use to just kind
of manage my youtube channel.
CorePower on Demand.
This has also been a savior
while I've been in lockdown.
I used to always go to core power classes,
and one of the things that I noticed is,
the core power classes
were always hot yoga,
and I was struggling in
their sculpt classes.
And now that I've been
doing these classes at home,
not in 110 degree temperatures,
they're so much easier.
Erewhon is a grocery store.
I've been using this
to get food delivered,
I've also been using
it for cab side pickup.
Zoom, I think we all know what zoom is.
Notes, I take so many
notes in the notepad,
that's like my go to.
WebEx for some more conference calls,
and all kinds of fun meetings.
Selects and Safe keep that
connects to a Gnar box.
It's a little hard drive
that you can put SD cards in,
and you can use it when you're on the go.
So you won't need a computer,
it'll automatically backup your SD cards.
And these are the apps
that go along with that,
because it will connect to your iPad,
you can transfer photos
directly from that drive,
to your iPad and
automatically start editing.
Skype for some more virtual calls.
I've been doing so many virtual calls,
it's crazy how everything
has just completely shifted
to virtual meetings as
opposed to in person.
Mean we don't have a choice,
so it's kind of like
we've been forced into it.
Procreates.
Oh my gosh, this is what I've
been using it for (laughs).
Started a little garden
and Animal Crossing.
I wanted to make sure that I had,
kind of like an archive
of all the flowers.
We have Google Docs, Discord.
I'm actually started a Discord server.
So just pace yourself.
I'm pacing myself.
I never use discord that much before,
but now that I've been
doing a lot of like,
Animal Crossing stuff, trying
to connect with you guys,
and doing a lot more streaming,
especially with my sister,
who just started her Twitch channel,
which is really exciting.
Discord reminds me of
the old school IRC days.
That's where I spent so much
of, well it's not my childhood.
I mean, I guess I still
was technically a child,
but all through high school,
like IRC was what I
spent most of my time on.
Frame.io, this is what we
use to do file transfers.
I have a full video
coming out very shortly,
talking about our work from home workflow.
And Frame.io plays such
a huge part in that.
Photoshop for iPad, is pretty awesome.
It's obviously not a full fledged version,
like on a desktop, but if you need to do,
pretty much most of the things,
that you would need to do in Photoshop,
you can do it here on the iPad.
So that's everything that
is on my iPad right now.
I would love to know if
there's any other apps
you guys would like me to check out.
I'm so excited though,
because I do plan on
doing a full AR video,
when some of the new
AR apps are coming out,
that support the LiDAR sensor.
But until then, hope
you guys are doing well,
and I look forward to
seeing you guys in the raid.
Don't forget to join my clan.
Vimana video games that I used
to play was pretty excessive,
and then I found Jiu
Jitsu about two years ago.
So that kind of took over
almost all of my free time.
Jiu Jitsu for me was kind
of like a real life video,
because there's strategy involved,
you're also getting the
added physical benefits,
of working out,
while also kind of challenging
your skills and strategy,
so I really, really miss it a lot.
But I also miss playing video games.
(upbeat music)